on gère ça on n'a pas le choix donc j'ai
la chance d'avoir des enfants
extraordinaires
qui essayent de protéger leur maman et
maximum il faut pas oublier aussi les
deux premiers enfants de jean pierre je
suis rennais olivier qui sont aussi
extraordinaire et qu'on est tous soudés
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué parce
que ça présente c'est tout le temps là
j'arrive toujours pas à croire qu'ils
aient qui est parti j'ai toujours
l'impression qu'il va franchir la porte
mais
il a vraiment dire quand on voit les
images pardon
mais je suis très heureuse d'être avec
vous ou nous aussi on est content de te
voir je suis remercie de tout le soutien
que vous m'avez donné aussi c'est quoi
les mots que tu as eue nathalie avec
avec les enfants le soir où vous êtes
retrouvés pour la première fois son sang
sont jean pierre qui était le jean
pierre en hausse et voilà c'était
vraiment c'était le ciment avec voilà de
la famille c'était un incroyable
ce jour que j'ai souvent pensé à toi et
je me suis dit comment elle a géré ce
soir avec voilà et se retrouver sans
jean pierre à la maison c'est un vide
immense qu'est ce tu n'auras dixou vous
êtes dit
mais que c'est surtout mes enfants qui
ont plus parlé que moi ça qui est
impressionnant qui vont du moment on est
là tu n'es pas tout seul on veut
protéger parce que on super ton
supporterait pas de perdre parce que
c'est vrai que
une fois qu'il est parti c'est un peu
compliqué de vivre non je pense à plein
de choses
mais il faut que je me batte pour lui
pas pardon je suis il
faut que je me batte pour lui faut que
je me batte pour les études pour mes
enfants pour qu'ils réussissent leur vie
donc c'est ça qui me donne le punch
parce que je sais que pour lui ses
enfants c'était primordial notion donc
jeu et puis comme vous savez je crois
vraiment à la vie après la mort on va en
parler dans un instant ça parce que
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable ce que
tu vas te dire ça m'aide énormément mais
c'est vrai que mes enfants c'est
vraiment d amour qu'est ce qui t'a dit
jean-pierre ce que vous avez un moment
quand il était
très très mal est-ce que vous avez une
dernière discussion tous les deux que
vous êtes dit souvent ouais c'est vrai
vraiment souvent mais moi j'étais
toujours sans tabou alors est vraiment
tu le disais oui moi je disais plein de
choses et puis
on n'est pas immortel mais j'ai toujours
dit qu'il partirait pas d'un cancer et
en fin de compte il est parti d'un avc
massif donc il n'est pas parti du cancer
pour moi
[Musique]
c'était quelqu'un vraiment
d'extraordinaire sauf à ça tout le monde
le sait c'est idiot ce que je dis mais
à la fin c'est quelqu'un extrêmement
fort il m'impressionnait parce que avant
chaque fois il avait un petit peu mal à
la tête ça y est j'ai de la fièvre de la
fille faisait de la fièvre et là les
derniers mois ça a été
ultra forts ils pensaient qu enfant à
moi pour le protéger pour ce il n'était
plus là c'était la grande hantise il l'a
dit ça ils vont ils ont parlé de ça et
vous disais que si je pars je lui disais
toujours
il ya eu une opération pour son coeur
donc
les médecins étaient entrés dans la
chambre pour y dire madame monsieur
pernaut
l'opération du coeur ça devrait bien se
passer mais on a peur que vous le
fassiez de nouveau à notre a abaissé ce
qui pourrait être fatal pour vous
pendant l'opération qu'est-ce qu'on fait
monsieur pernaut est ce qu'on voulait ce
parti où est-ce qu'on fait tout pour
vous faire revenir si vous faites un avc
et là
moi je lui ai dit rappelle toi chérie
même s'il fait un avc moi je veux bien
te pousser en chaise roulante on a assez
des cônes et là dessus
parce que je disais toujours façon à 17
ans de plus que moi il ya un moment est
ce que d'ailleurs quand on avait acheté
notre maison déjà je saute du coq à
l'âne
et je dis ah bah c'est bien parce que
notre maison à l'est près d'une d'une
maison de retraite et un cimetière donc
je lui disais hé ben au moins je te
poussera en chaise roulante à la maison
de retraite parce que moi je j'aurai
besoin de courir je n'ai pas su mettre
l'ambiance wam
et puis après je dis ce qui sera
pratique c'est que le cimetière il n'est
pas loin je pourrais me recueillir tout
le temps alors monde et connaît beaucoup
elle jean-pierre là d'ssus c'était
important c'est quoi les derniers mots
qui te dit joe klein
ça a été difficile
derniers jours c'était compliqué parce
que là il a eu les reins qui sont
bloqués d'enquêté en dialyse il divague
et un petit peu
c'est surtout avant moi les les paroles
que je lui disais c'est que quand il
s'en est sorti de son opération
je suis rentré dans la chambre et je dis
waouh t'es warriors tu va tous nous
enterrer tu es ultra fort tu te rends
compte que tu as fait une opération du
coeur des encore là je suis fier de toi
il me regarde et me fait ça et alors là
je la gueule comme d'habitude le pauvre
jean revenait tout le temps et il ya ces
jeudi mais non je ne fais pas ça et j'ai
dit je suis sûr tu va tous nous enterrez
puis après bon bah ça s'est dégradé donc
il me demandait toujours comment vont
les enfants ça va bien les enfants et
puis c'est vrai qu'à une chose qui est
compliqué c'est que tous les soirs je
quitté l'hôpital vers 21h et ce soir là
la dernière fois à 18h30
les médecins m'ont demandé de partir
parce qu'ils m'ont dit faut que je me
repose parce que depuis le mois de
janvier j'étais tout le temps auprès de
lui jusqu'à 21h ils m'ont écouté on va
lui faire un examen
annie rn donc il va vous reposer c'est
pas la peine que vous l'accompagnez
quand je tiens banon mais il a
l'habitude que je la compagne parce
qu'ils aiment passer
cet examen là et dit non mais de façon
plus y'a du monde d'en bas et tout
allait vous reposez vous reviendrez
demain et c'est la seule fois là que
j'ai pas pu la juge lembras tout le
temps là j'étais au bout de son lipsky
avait plein de professeurs et je
remercierai jamais assez les professeurs
aussi à l'hôpital pompidou parce qu'ils
ont fait tout leur possible et
j'ai juste j'étais à ses pieds j'ai pris
ses pieds comme cela et je je t'aime
enchérit t'inquiète pas pour pour
paulhan terme pour pour le clairement
pardon pour l'examen et tous les je suis
là dès demain tu t'inquiètes pas
t'inquiète pas et c'est la première et
la gelée pas serrer dans mes bras comme
je faisais tous les soirs c'est ça qui
est terrible et ça sentirait moins que
ces tutus moi je savais que
juste je savais que j'y vois des
pressentiments va me dire que je suis
folle et tout ça mais je savais qu'il
passerait pas ses 72 ans
j'en ai parlé à ma meilleure amie au
petit ami de ma fille laura médicaux
voiture avec 10 juin il ya plus de dix
ans je disais j'ai très peur parce que
je vois pas jean pierre a fêté ses
soixante douze ans
comment tu as eu ce flash et quand c'est
pas un flash c'est un truc à l'intérieur
c'est viscéral 72 ans cliente à l'hôtel
je voyais ce c'est viscéral c'est comme
si quelqu'un me parle on ne parle pas
j'entends pas de voix mais c'est un truc
qu'on le dit 72 ans va être compliqué 72
ans va être compliqué et toujours moi
c'était le coeur et la tête et le coeur
c'est thrombose et avc massive voilà
donc c'est pour ça je les ai toujours à
jean-pierre t'inquiète pas tu ne m'auras
pas d'un cancer tu mourras pas d'un
cancer mais j'ai jamais pu lui dire bien
sûr je ne voyais pas faire ces 72 heures
durant évidemment le dio et donc j'avais
très peur quand elle a commencé en
janvier à faire des avc sinon c'est en
tout il a fait 12 min avc et le 13e il a
été fatal
donc vous vous dire qu'il était puissant
effort et
et voilà il ya enfin voila je savais que
ce serait plutôt le coeur et la tête et
je me suis pas trompé malheureusement
parce qu'il est mort juste avant ses 72
ans il est parti de mars et il allait
avoir 72 ans le 8 avril c'est fou c'est
fou et ça ça te stresse et pas de savoir
ça demain si mais j'essaie toujours de
me remet à ma tête que je ne peux me
tromper je vais vraiment pays les plus
forts que ça nous la montrer à sa
puissance il est élu renfort il n'était
il vécut les fans il essayait de se
battre pour les autres gens qui avaient
le cancer il a été très fort je suis mis
à ses côtés parce qu'au début ils
avaient peur parler du cancer mais je me
suis toujours battu pour quoi que ce
soit à bout il s'est rangé auprès de moi
pour voilà montrer le côté positif qu'il
a toujours montré et jusqu'au bout il a
été positif parce que même la veille de
son opération
il était fort bon il n'avait pas dormi
de la nuit c'est évident ça tout le
monde aux urnes mais quand je lis bon
alors ça me fait penser à quoi une femme
j'ai réfléchi j'ai réfléchi je fais mais
à quoi est il me regarde on a plein de
choses ont chaud elle joue à quoi tu
penses alors je dis surtout si tu arrive
quoi que ce soit n'oublie pas je sais
que tu te moques de moi quand je te
parle de ça mais c'est moi des signes
j'ai dit sinon ce qui ne fait pas des
signes gérer et étranglée donc j'ai dit
la première chose qu'il faudra que tu le
fasses dessine et tu verras quand tu
partiras si jamais tu dois partir
tu verras tu diras à merde elle avait
encore raison alors tu nous a parlé
peut-être ces mini s'investit qu'a fait
jean pire je me rappelle à une époque
j'étais face au professeur raoul qui
étaient là à l'époque un jour vous étiez
invité ensemble tirer c'est un moment
assez fort vous aviez demandé si le
vaccin aurait pu causer les mini avis
est que jean pierre a subi ce que tu
pose encore la question que ça tu es
passé à autre chose que je me rappelle
que c'était un truc qui te trotter dans
la tête sur apple qui tenait en avait
parlé avant l'émission dumont avait
parlé après tu avais profité que le
professeur raoul soit là pour en parler
dans la tête m s oui c'est logique c'est
logique mais
les vaccins tellement aidé des gens
aussi bah oui donc je suis pas médecin
pour dire que
que c'est à cause de sa non pas du tout
mais ferait que son corps était ultra
fragilisé parce qu'il avait quand même
eu une opération au mois de juin pour le
cancer du poumon mais c'est compliqué
j'aimerais bien comprendre je comprends
pas que d'un coup ils effet plaints à
baisser comme ça j'ai du mal et des
thromboses mais il est rond pose partout
quoi je j'ai du mal à comprendre je vais
parce que franchement quand je vous dis
qu'il est pas mort du cancer j'avais la
preuve parce que au mois de janvier la
ferme pescade et surpasse cannes il ya
le plus de traces de cancer bien
évidemment quand on dit qui avait plus
de trace de cancer ça veut pas dire que
complètement guérie ça se passe dans
trois mois il y aurait à nouveau quelque
chose mais il y avait plus de trace de
cancer donc
donc voilà donc j'ai d'ailleurs j'avais
j'avais appelé florent pagny parce que
je voulais absolument qu'ils sachent que
jean-pierre n'était pas mort du cancer
bien sûr parce que je veux que qui reste
sur ce bonne amie commune et florent
pagny et je trouve admirable
comment il est motion et je le remercie
parce que il donne beaucoup d'espoir à
beaucoup de gens alors on est deux mois
après le ces deux mois que jean pierre
nous a quittés mois et demi deux mois et
demi whatcott comment tu vas aujourd'hui
est-ce que tu arrives pas ce que ça
n'arrive pas ou tu y as des eaux il ya
débat il ya
jeu on survit comme on dit on survit
orphelin guillaume avec le temps ça va
passer ben moi je trouve que plus les
gens n'aient pas ses percées je je je
vois pas d'amélioration parce que au
début on se dit ah bah il est parti
travailler moi je suis en tournée ou
voilà en fait puis moi j'étais quelqu'un
on était très indépendant aussi nature
c'est à dire que moi des fois je partais
une semaine en vacances tout seul voilà
on n'était pas tout le temps et j'y vois
là j'ai l'impression qu'il va franchir
la porte et la franchit pas mais mais il
est présent il est présent à côté de moi
il est ça je suis 100% sûr c'est pas
pour me dire pour me rassurer parce
qu'il ya plein de gens guillaume c'est
pour te rassurer non non c'est pas pour
me rassurer je sais qu'il est proche de
moi qu'il est à côté de moi qui me
protège comme il l'a toujours fait
d'ailleurs on s'est toujours protéger
mutuellement je vais sauver la vie
plusieurs fois maintenant c'est lui qui
me sauve et c'est lui au moins le jour
où je partirai il sera le premier à me
retrouver les enfants convaincants ils
vont les enfants c'est compliqué c'est
très difficile vraiment à wii s'est très
vite sinon malin deux mois et demi ces
six familles sont à milito huit ans j'ai
pu te papa tellement jeune sans papa et
c'était leur mentor ils étaient
tellement un bon père tellement généreux
avec ses enfants
loulou bien sûr à l'été sur les réseaux
où elle rigole où elle m'a jamais chaque
enfant est complètement différent elle
rigole parce qu'elle essaye de montrer
une autre facette mai elle pleure
énormément j'ai vu qu'on lui avait
reproché
alignement de rigoler sur les réseaux
combien
série qui s'emmerdent et qui doivent
faire des critiques moi je trouve que ma
fille énormément de courage parce que
elle veut montrer un côté positif comme
l a dit son deuil ses personnels
donc c'est clair que le soir et ben
comme moi on pleure elle ne pas pleurer
dans mes bras parce qu'elle va être
forte pour moi dans quel cdn pour une
gamine de 19 ans de soutenir sa merde
pas de pleurer devant sa mère parce
qu'elle va me soutenir elle a été triste
de ce qui s'est dit sur les réseaux
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai vu sur les
réseaux des bus kallel ou la fille de
jean pierre qui a fait pas mal de vidéos
il ya plein de deux d'abrutis qui ont
dit oui son père revient de partir elle
fait des vidéos sur les réseaux c'est
honteux c'est inadmissible est ce
qu'elle est ce que ça la salle à payer
ou bien au début oui au début oui puis
après diop merde c'est ce que je lui dis
j'ai dit tu faisais quand tu te mets sur
les réseaux il faut tout accepter il y
en a qui sont contents il y en a qui
sont pas contents jeudi l'essentiel faut
que toi tu sois bien dans ta tête c'est
ce qui est pris ce qui est primordial et
1,18 à raison moment donc des fois leur
balance des bonnes pic et puis a dit
l'essentiel les gens qui me connaissent
bien et qui même une comprennent donc
voilà les autres c'est pas grave on s'en
fout
alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tu tu nous as
dit
dernièrement que tu avais des
des petits signes de chant pierre parce
que c'est vrai que c'est fou si vous
entendre ce que vous nous en dire
nathalie quand est-ce que ça démarre il
m'a dit qu'il est parti quand il est
parti
à son dernier souffle je suis parti
après l'hôpital pourtant j étais tous
les jours jamais la tour eiffel s'est
illuminé et pourtant tous les jours gt1
et le jour où il est mort je suis sorti
j'étais avec mon amie muriel la tour
eiffel est éliminé et la tour eiffel
c'était très important pour tous les
deux parce que c'était notre première
rencontre pour le restaurant donc pour
toi tu es tu te tue les prix comme moi
je me suis dit voilà chérie je suis là
t'inquiète pas on regarde notre tour
eiffel jeu l'éclair pour toi je prends
la voiture
elles étaient au moins deux au parking
et je démarre la voiture pourtant moins
deux ans on capte pas la musique de
johnny hallyday musique que je faisais
écouter quand tu étais pas dans le coma
mais en semi sommeil musique de john et
le lendemain je dis à mon amie muriel va
falloir trouver un mot de code pour pas
que il ya des gens mal intentionnés qui
veulent faire des photos sur le lit de
mort de jean-pierre faut faire très
attention aux funérailles funérarium
donc j'ai dit on va mettre un mot de
passe et puis moi je sais pas je sais
pas pourquoi mais je pensais la nature
jeudi ben on va dire le mot sapin et là
ma copine me regarde ça c'est glauque
sapin comme moi je dis ah bah oui c'est
vrai t'as raison pardon va peut-être pas
mettre sapin on trouvera autre chose je
prends la voiture je vais à l'hôpital
pour aller voir mon jean pierre était
plus là mais voilà près de lui et je
garde la voiture au parking à pompidou
encore une fois je sors de la voiture on
a mis elle sort aussi est là deux
branches de morceaux de sapins sur la
roue arrière gauche un truc de dingue
rome et s'est ensuite ma fille
avant de m'endormir jeudi jean-pierre
j'aimerais bien que tu me fasses un
signe là j'ai besoin j'ai besoin sans
doute de celui par les contenus j'ai pas
beaucoup moi j'ai fait que ça va le tout
comme ça tu es temps là d'un choix mais
je m'en fous pibor alain moi je suis pas
logique et voilà ça ça va être père sava
pas de plaire tu parles comme ça tout
seul tu ne t'es pas tout seul mais pour
nan chen hong ben on n'est pas tout seul
personne était donc tu dis ouais
jean-pierre j'aimerais bien qu'ils me
fassent en signe ce soir oui donc j'ai
été vers minuit et demi un truc comme ça
je dis moi que tu me fasses asim que ça
fait un petit peu longtemps là et puis
bon je commence à m'endormir et là j'ai
ma fille qui me téléphonent à 1h15 du
matin maman maman papa m'a fait ainsi il
m'a fait un signe soit pas de la chance
je vais demander avant de m'endormir il
l'a fait pour toi m dit oui mais j'étais
avec ma copine dans mon salon parce
qu'elle elle a pris un appartement et et
ont discuté avec ma copine la télé s'est
allumée et il y avait un film il ya le
comédien qui dit je suis fier de toi ma
fille la télé c'est tes potes
et ma fille m'a dit maman maman maman et
apprennent mon fils il était en était un
peu en colère parce qu'il n'y aurais je
comprends pas moi j'ai pas de signe
c'est des conneries et tout ça et touche
parce que tu les vois pas il faut être
prêt il faut les voir et pendant le
débat précise bercy
tom il à ce que j'ai mis une grande
photo dans mon salon de jean-pierre et
tous et tom il n'arrêtait pas de dire
papa fais moi un signe pas pas fait -
s'il n'y pas pas fait -6 et lâchez pas
j'imite homme laisse le tranquille à une
finance je veux un signe je veux un
signe et au bout d'une demi heure il y
avait la télé donc lui regarder la télé
dans le salon et moi j'étais dans ma
chambre en train de regarder la télé le
débat et la télé s'est arrêtée arrêt sur
images au bout d'une demi-heure et moi
ma télé avait sur image fait comme je
suis en train de regarder les élections
qu'est ce que tu as fait tu me salis
j'ai eu mon signe papa il a fait arrêter
la télé et après les himbas il dit peut
passer vosges et on signe la télé c'est
remy normalement en marche sauf que la
mienne elle est restée bloquée sur tf1
j'ai pas pu regarder continue sur tf1
mais j'ai pu regarder sur la deux non
c'est fou
mais le truc dément et y avait un autre
truc aussi très flagrant j'ai fait un
rêve
j'étais avec jean-pierre y conduisait
sur l'autoroute
et jeudi mais merde mais comment je vais
lui dire qu'il est mort parce qu'il sait
pas qu'il est mort et puis on va avoir
un accident de voiture mais je peux pas
lui dire qu'il est mort il ne s'est même
pas et puis rigolent ils roulent en
voiture et tout comment je vais lui dire
que manger et puis je me réveille
subitement je fais tiens c'est bizarre
il va se passer quelque chose et j'étais
à lille chez des amis je dormais chez
des amis parce que j'étais allé pour un
salon du livre et donc je j'en parle à
mes amis je leur explique et je dis bah
il va se passer quelque chose
aujourd'hui donc je vais au salon du
livre je commence à signer d'autographes
et où il ya un monsieur qui vient vers
moi une qui vous savez qu'il ya une
voyante qui est lâche-t-il avant le
salon de lille fait mouiller les
derrières cacher mon la voit pas trop
moi de mamie elle m'a dit des choses
surprenantes j'ai planté tous les gens
pour les autres nona je suis désolé je
m'absente dix minutes c'est sûr que j'ai
un gel va devoir me donner un message je
vais la voir
donc elle me voit elle et elle commence
à pleurer elle m'a dit tellement c'est
bon ça c'est facile à dire mais elles
disent ça fait une semaine que je savais
qu'on allait se rencontrer et j'ai dit
oui bah alors j'ai dit vous avez des
messages je voulais les fuites la pauvre
jeune un peu traumatisés et elle me dit
oui déjà le premier message il a enfin
compris qu'il était mort et moi dans la
nuit je me suis dit merde il a pas
compris c'est pas qu'il ait menacé pas
besoin est et j'ai dit il ya autre chose
elle me dit oui et il est en train de me
dire que ce cas elle rigolé après en
même temps au moment où il est parti il
dit et oui tu avais encore raison et
c'est la phrase que je lui ai dit et
c'est la phrase que je lui ai dit à jean
pierre quand il est parti je suis dit tu
verras ton homme sera là haut que tu me
diras merde elle avait encore raison
donc elle a véhiculé ça c'est quand même
incroyable
et elle m'avait parlé aussi d'une montre
une dit wim parle d'une montre qu'il
faut pas oublier de la donnée de la
donner à 20 ans et je sais qu'il avait
une montre qu'il aimait bien jean-pierre
et que vous voulez que tom les pour 50
ans parce qu'il a dit il est un peu
jeune pour la voir donc on fait comment
il peut avoir tous ces signes comment
elle a pas lu dans mes pensées après
j'ai été voir aussi bruno qui parle
bruno un message qui parle avec les
morts donc ça fait bizarre quand on dit
ça moi la toute première fois quand on
m'a dit ça j'en ai été voir directement
et laurie et donc il m'a je peux pas
tout vous raconter mais tout de suite il
m'a montré bien qu'il était là il dit
oui il en train de me dire qu'il était
très fier de ce que votre fils louf il
m'a dit exactement ce qui avait mis dans
le cercueil sur la dans la poche gauche
et il est très fier et ses îles ç'aurait
pu être moi sa première fille son fils
tom non c'était sa fille était très fier
qui le remercie et c'était exact et
plein d'autres choses qui étaient
exactes mais il y aurait là une va vivre
comme ça on se dise on sait si c'est oui
parce que je sais que lui ça doit leur
assurer excusez moi en me dire ça
surprend une fois mais ça me rassure et
aussi parce que ils n'arrêtent pas quand
je reçois des messages ou des voyants
qu'ils arrêtent pas de demander pardon
pardon ne pas m'avoir cru pardon de
cette moquer d'un peu de mon livre mais
parce qu'il a eu le temps de lire mon
livre aussi moi j'y crois justement je
parlais de ça c'est quand même
impressionnant d'avoir osé écrire ce
livre qui est sorti en octobre et qu'il
est parti là en mars
alors on va rappeler le livre 1 nathalie
pour nos téléspectateurs à mais c'était
moi j'y crois chez merci moi j'y crois
chez très daniel oui où tu disais donc
je parle de mes hanches de mai
prémonition attendant c'est comme ça que
j'ai pu sauver plusieurs fois l'avis de
jean-pierre on n'a jamais pu lui dire il
passerait pas ses 72 ans était c'était
impensable que je lui dise sauf à des
amis proches pour qu'on voit que je suis
pas folle et ce que je ressens
elle
donc voilà donc il avait lu ce livre est
des fois il se moquait un peu de moi et
me dit ah ouais c'est un peu bizarre un
ton truc et toi je dis ouais mais
j'étais sauvé la vie quand même non et
ouais nan c'est vrai je dis tu as pu
vous allez voir ton frère grâce à moi
parce que je savais j'ai donné à la date
exacte de la mort de son frère dont il a
eu plus voir son frère aussi dongo et
non c'est vrai c'est vrai je suis tu
verras plus tard tu feras plus tard et
c'est bizarre qu'il a lu ce livre est
que ça se passe maintenant il n'y a pas
de dégâts pas de hasard moi je dis qu a
pas de hasard une pression se
rencontrent tous là haut après qu'en
soient juifs musulmans catholiques c'est
tous pour tout le monde pareil c'est fou
dans ce que tu nous racontes ce qu'on se
dit ça doit être non pas en avoir peur
non maintenant parce que les gens qui
veulent communiquer avec vous c'est
c'est important parce que eux ils sont
très bien là où c'est ce qu'on nous dit
et s'ils sont dans la lumière ils font
plein d'autres choses après là haut donc
non non ils sont très très bien et c'est
vrai moi pour m'endormir enfin c'est
tout con mais j'écoute toujours sur des
sur youtube des trucs a émis les gens
qui qui qui sont partis mais qui sont
revenus en fin qui a par exemple un
arrêt cardiaque mais ils sont revenus ou
pendant une opération est tout et
racontent tous la même chose et on a de
plus en plus 7000 au moins deux cas par
an en france le mort imminente alors
imminente
sans plus pardon oui nation oui c'est
bouleversant votre témoignage sur la
force de l'amour et de la spiritualité
est ce que parfois il s'adresse
directement à vous ou est ce que dans la
vie quotidienne vous faites quelque
chose et vos dit tiens c'est lui qui a
dû m'inciter à faire sa
dernière fois un truc bête je suis par
gilles diment j'espère je serai à la
hauteur pour les études des enfants
concerts jeux dit comme ça ça coûte cher
et tout mais bon on y arrivera et tout
y'a pas de soucis et tout et puis je
vais dans ma cuisine et puis j'entends
dans la voix va dans la bibliothèque va
dans la bibliothèque je me tue ce que je
dit avant moi je suis dit mais qu'est ce
que tu veux que j'aille faire qu'est ce
qui me passe ça c'est un truc qui me dit
pourquoi aller dans la bibliothèque donc
je suis bon je vais dans la bibliothèque
et je prends un livre il ya une grande
bibliothèque j'ai choisi un livre il y
avait 500 euros en liquide dedans
un truc de dingue j'ai appelé mon fils
ma fille je vais regarder un truc de
dingue c'est bien faut voir s'étaler
dans la bibliothèque
[Rires]
de livres 1 donc
moi je suis parle beaucoup je suis pas
donc des fois je les engueule aussi
parce que y'a mon fils il fait les
courses de bagnoles et puis il y avait
deux courses de voitures à faire et je
savais que pour mon fils était le plus
important qu'ils gagnent cette course
parce qu'ils avaient envie de remettre
cette coupe au cimetière et là j'ai pas
compris il a fait la première cause
s'est retrouvé dernier choses qui
arrivent rarement en général peu dans
les dix premiers mais là dernier donc je
me mets dans mon coin et jean-pierre
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu protèges pas
ton fils mais merde tu te rends compte
pour lui la déception s'il veut gagner
cette coupe c'est pour toi donc tes
intérêts de remuer le popotin pour pour
la prochaine course dont qui part il
n'était pas dans les dents les premiers
part je suis plus dans 15e position et
où il part égale la course non c'est fou
et cette course là il n'avait jamais
gagné il avait déjà été deuxièmes
troisièmes mais ils ont pu faire bouger
le popotin et voilà c'est mon chef
tu peux te changer les idées grâce au
théâtre notamment ton spectacle et
tonton farceur c'est compliqué d'être
sur scène où on tournait où vient cette
change vraiment les idées au début ça a
été très compliqué si j'aimerais qu'on
l'avait enterré le mercredi et le samedi
j'ai été sur cet été sur ce nous sommes
dit oui parce que j'avais déjà annulé
pas mal de dates quand il est à
l'hôpital et il m'a engueulé jean-pierre
me dit mais non mais vas tu vas
travailler je me sens je me sens c'est
tellement compliqué pour toi d'être ici
s'est il se sentait les culpabilités il
était triste de voir tout le temps et je
suis maintenant mais ma place est auprès
de toi et tous unis non il faut que tu
ailles jouer je dis bah non j'ai pas
envie là donc je me suis dit une fois
qu'il est parti il serait tellement
fière parce qu'il m'avait vu il avait vu
deux fois c'est la pièce que nous avait
dit et ils adorent efficace et très fier
pas sûr même si je jouais mal serait
très fiable ou les miens même à mes
débuts quand j'étais et débutants
comédiennes ont été fabuleuses mais non
chérie ou non mais voilà non mais cette
pièce il l'adorait parce que c'est en
tournée dans toute la france oui à
l'alhambra à paris du 17 juin au 31
juillet c'est vrai que ça vous fait du
bien à thalys de ses lumières de c'est
une pièce
clac c'est une comédie donc
et moi j'ai l'impression qui qui est
avec moi dès que je joue il est avec moi
et il doit être très fier donc je suis
contente et il doit être contente
content pardon que je joue enfin sur
paris aussi de nouveau ce que c'est pas
évident de jouer sur paris et surtout
jours près de toi ouais voilà c'est
bernard montiel 1 mais
bernard montiel
moi je peux vous dire qu'il vous aimez
tout symbole m le même jour est vraiment
il nous manque et je peux vous dire qu'à
l'hôpital il avait envie de regarder tes
pmp il avait envie de rire et je suis
heureux tu veux pas m hind et non non
non je me tapais une plage de tpm paix
parce qu'ils riaient et ses dernières
émissions de télé cet été
vraiment innovante fort et on l'aimé
vraiment très très très très fort note
jean-pierre mas